now one question a lot of you have is
what's taking so long to get the ballots
counted here in nevada
election officials say two of the
reasons record turnout and it's the
first time they've had to deal with so
many mail-in ballots
and it's all slowing the process our
hector mejia is live outside the
election department this morning
standing by for those new numbers hi
hector
hey there good morning those numbers
will be released at nine o'clock this
morning talk about election day turning
into
election week and inside the election
department that is where the mail
ballots are being counted but election
workers are not counting those ballots
around the clock they're counting in
shifts starting from around five o'clock
in the morning
up until 11 o'clock at night until they
finish so let's go over the numbers and
tell you about the votes that still have
to be counted yesterday we were told
that there were still about 190 thousand
ballots that needed to be counted that's
according to the nevada secretary of
state's office
and with clark county having the biggest
population in nevada
90 percent of those votes are here in
our own county
and this morning joe biden's lead over
president donald trump and nevada could
either shrink or
widen as we get those numbers at 9 00
a.m
and then an hour later clark county will
give an update on their efforts
that's happening at 10 this morning and
here's the registrar voters joe gloria
[Music]
i think it's important for the entire
country to understand that mail ballots
on this scale is very new to the state
of nevada
we made a decision here to provide as
much access as we possibly could as a
result of the pandemic
and so our process has run a little bit
slower
legal observers from both parties are
allowed to view the county process
inside last night we saw a protest with
president
trump supporters forming outside
election headquarters
unhappy with how the results were going
so far and we all want to know the
results right but just imagine what it's
like
for the workers inside knowing that
they're carrying the weight of the
election on their shoulders right now
as not only us but the whole nation is
watching waiting for those results
to be released reporting live from north
las vegas hector mejia
8 news now